hey youtubers it's Charlie so the writer
on Captain Marvel said the character is
gonna get a new origin story in the
Marvel Universe because it's too similar
to another characters so here's a quick
breakdown of what's going on most of you
may have some idea for her origin story
in the comics it's been retconned a
couple times
the most recent version is that she
basically got caught in this giant
explosion with the Kree device and it
infused her with all this cosmic energy
so then she took up the title Captain
Marvel as a way to honor the original
Captain Marvel the Kree version of the
character so it gets a little
complicated with all the different
versions of Miss Marvel is is who the
character Carol Danvers used to be in
the comics in Captain Marvel so there's
a bunch of MS Marvel's there's a bunch
of Captain Marvel's the movies are just
going to simplify all that the writer of
the movie said that they will change her
origin story a little bit to fit with
what they've been doing in the movies
meaning as we've all kind of predicted
that they're gonna tie it to an infinity
gem because she's one of the most
powerful Marvel heroes that comes from
Earth and the only way to put her on the
level of Scarlet Witch and even like
vision who's I mean he's an AI he's to
give her an origin story that matches
that power level which is mean to
infinity stone but as with all things in
the movies when they changed the plot of
certain stories they always trying to
honor the comic book version with a
bunch of Easter eggs so I'm expecting a
lot of Captain Marvel Kree Easter eggs
when she gets her powers but no idea
when that's gonna happen during the
movie we only know that she's gonna
appear and then she'll go on to her
spin-off film Captain Marvel after that
I've already done a video for her origin
story so I'll put a link in the
description what we really need to talk
about now though is is which infinity
gem would she get her powers from would
it be the mind gem like vision the only
way to do that would pry B to rip it out
of his skull so I don't know if they'd
want to do that I mean they'll have to
do it eventually because Thanos will
need it to assemble the Infinity
Gauntlet which I do think that he will
achieve during infinity war but the only
other gems that haven't been used yet
are the time gem in the soul gem so if
you guys don't know who Adam warlock is
in the comics he eventually goes on to
call himself the ultimate Avenger so
he's a good character but that I mean
there's a lot of complicated backstory
because he has an evil persona called
the mages it was involved in a really
big infinity war comic book story
that involve fan OHS assembling the
gauntlet then it's spinning into a bunch
of other big cosmic stories it's like
this really big cosmic part of the
Marvel Universe that the movies haven't
even touched on you do not need to worry
about it at all but I think the Captain
Marvel will kind of fill that at a
warlock ultimate avenger role meaning
that Adam warlock who possessed the soul
gem in the comics will probably go to
Captain Marvel so odds are right now
that if she gets her power from an
infinity gem it'll be the soul gem I
think the time gem is going to be Doctor
Strange relative but there's a number of
different things that they could do so
here's my big question for you which gem
do you think is gonna give Captain
Marvel her powers in Avengers infinity
war and at what point in the movie do
you think that's gonna happen they could
do it a couple different ways one they
could do the Spider Man thing like they
did in civil weren't like when he showed
up for the first time he had already
become spider-man he just didn't have a
really amazing stark tech costume yet so
in the movie we could meet her as this
test pilot who has already gotten her
powers and is trying to figure them out
or we meet Air Force pilot Carol Danvers
and she somehow comes into contact with
the Infinity gem and gets her powers
while the Avengers are nearby like
during the course of events in the movie
so I know there's a whole lot of
questions like everybody wants to know
what's going on but the good thing is is
we have a couple movies before we get to
infinity war so a lot of what happens
during those will determine what happens
next so once we see some of the
post-credits scenes in the next Marvel
movies we'll have a better idea for
what's going on with the Infinity
Gauntlet the infinity gems because that
will largely determine what ends up
happening at the beginning of Avengers
infinity war how that gem comes into
contact with Carol Danvers right now the
only movies that I'm expecting to
directly address that are Thor Ragnarok
you know because of this teaser they
gave us a comic-con who is the purple
man in the chair trying to assemble the
glove who is this person and then dr.
strange because that gets into
multiverse really cosmic altered states
of the universe stuff you know very very
big ideas and that's what if Finity
words gonna be it's gonna be the
culmination of a bunch of the biggest
ideas in the Marvel Universe so Doctor
Strange coming in November we might get
some Inklings of infinity war stuff that
is really gonna introduce the multiverse
into the Marvel Universe everybody knows
about the multiverse I mean it's really
a simple concept
but they haven't really addressed it in
the movies yet so technically if the
movies don't address something it
doesn't exist like if something doesn't
get mentioned or they don't hinted
something or it's not in the subtext it
doesn't exist so until we see dr.
strange
there is no multiverse yet but I mean we
know it's there just because they told
us it's there but surprisingly guardians
of the galaxy isn't gonna get into too
much infinity award stuff it's largely
self-contained the way James Gunn
explains it no Thanos no infinity gem in
that movie you know even though they're
gonna be dealing with some very cosmic
ideas and funny enough you know Captain
Marvel in like the one previous run of
the comic book she crossed over there
was a big star-lord story with his
father this big Galactic Empire it went
a little crazy but it is just funny the
Captain Marvel just did a big crossover
with the guardians of the galaxy and
we're getting ready for infinity war
which will be that Guardians crossover
but you don't need to read any of those
comics to understand what's going on as
long as you have a basic idea for who
the character is like where she comes
from she comes from the military kind of
you know the her power levels and what
her psychology is like how is she
different from the other Avengers in the
way she tackles problems the simplest
way I could explain her is that she's
from the military like Captain America
but she's like Captain America on 10
cups of coffee like she's just like very
quick to make decisions very sure of the
course of action that she wants to take
and she largely deals in absolutes
because her biggest job right now is
taking care of the entire planet
protecting it from external alien
threats so everything that comes across
her desk is a life-or-death situation so
you kind of begin to understand why it
is she's so hardcore even though a lot
of her energy flows from the same place
of Captain America it's just the Captain
America has played a little bit more
like a boy scout
she comes off as like a little more
argumentative than that and obviously
she's a lot more powerful than Captain
America so that's why I'm just gonna
call her like the ten cups of coffee
version of Captain America but I'm
expecting brie Larson like she's an
amazing actress to infuse a lot of her
own energy into the character so we'll
learn all about the pathos of movie
Captain Marvel when we see her an
infinity war
but in the way we saw Scarlet Witch for
the first time in Avengers age of Ultron
then we got to like the next movie Civil
War and that really dealt with her
psychology I would expect
the same type of treatment with the
Captain Marvel character we'll learn a
little bit about what's going on in her
head during infinity war then when they
get to her solo movie they'll really go
for the deep dive like you really
learned what she's all about the next
real big question is is who is going to
be the villain of the Captain Marvel
movie that's something we ought to talk
about like a whole of the video but just
think about it this way if they want to
keep the movie on earth it's gonna be
really hard for them to do some of her
bigger villains because a lot of them
come from the Kree in the comics and
that's very galactic so just remains to
be seen how earth-based the Captain
Marvel movie is going to be there just
like a couple big villains that they
have not done from the comics aim is a
big Captain Marvel villain but I don't
know if they would opt to do MODOK I
mean we're almost at the place where we
could get away with doing MODOK they
might borrow villains from some of the
other movies and it might just be an
extension of what happens during
infinity war it will definitely have to
address what happens in infinity war
because in the timeline it will be
happening after so I definitely think
they'll be at least a little bit of
galactic stuff happening in her movie
but I just can't wait to see the other
Avengers try to figure out what to do
with her like Tony can barely handle
Scarlet Witch and vision right now what
is he gonna do when another gem powered
person comes along cause be like oh my
god I'm gonna call in sick today and
just go to Queens and hang out with
spider-man and his hot Aunt May if you
couldn't already tell I'm very excited
about that spider-man movie so there'll
be a new Spider Man video probably
sometime in the next week but tomorrow
new Game of Thrones so be sure to
subscribe to get it
there's supposed to be a Walking Dead
Season 7 preview so I'll probably be
doing a video for that too later that
night so while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about Captain Marvel's back
story in the comics and you can click
here for the Black Panther Comic Con
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight